en la recta final para la segunda vuelta
de las elecciones presidenciales el más
reciente sondeo de la encuestadora ipec
sigue dándole la victoria al
expresidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
pero por un margen más reducido
dos partidos que estas elecciones no son
entre dos partidos políticos o dos seres
humanos esta elección es la elección que
definirá si queremos vivir en un régimen
democrático o si queremos el Neo
fascismo Lula obtendría un 50% de los
votos frente al 43% que recibiría Jair
bolsonaro y mientras tanto la campaña
transcurre entre acusaciones el equipo
del presidente yaer bolsonaro denunció
ante el tribunal electoral y la Corte
Suprema un presunto saboteo en su contra
el coordinador de la campaña dijo que
más de 140.000 anuncios de la propaganda
obligatoria por radio y televisión no
fueron transmitidos por los medios y
pidió auditorías para analizarlas
irregularidades
solo en el noreste en la semana pasada
del 7 al 14 de octubre fueron 12.000
anuncios menos y la semana siguiente del
14 al 21 subió a 17.000
mientras bolsonaro Afirma sin fundamento
que podría haber fraude en los comicios
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva el ganador de
la primera vuelta que obtuvo 48,4%
frente al 43,2% de su contrincante
continúa enfocando su Campaña en que el
pueblo debe escoger entre la democracia
y la barbarie sin embargo las encuestas
en el país han sido duramente criticadas
luego de que las proyecciones para la
primera vuelta se alejaran por un gran
margen del resultado Real